ces habitats rambouillet je suis sage
femme depuis cinq ans je travaille en
hospitalisation à domicile depuis deux
ans après avoir travaillé pendant trois
ans à l'hôpital
bonjour la journée commence toujours par
un temps de prière à l'oratoire
j'ai besoin de cette respiration pour
ordonner ma journée et l'a recommandé
dans la prière et la vivre avec le
seigneur après celle de la messe ou les
lourdes je pars en tournée
voir mes patientes c'est la tournée de
la cigogne entraygues lit mais je vois
en général trois ou quatre patientes le
matin bonjour
après entre midi et deux shows croise
mes collègues au bureau ou à la
maternité et le soir je rentre soit
directement soit en envoyant à nouveau
deux ou trois patientes ça fait des
bonnes journées ça fait pas mal de
kilomètres mais ça fait aussi beaucoup
de rencontres
et puis ça me fait vivre aussi beaucoup
à l'extérieur donc tout le temps passé
sur la route tue à la lumière du jour
bon allez dernière ligne droite
toujours et encore le travail de la sage
femme
c'est le suivi de la grossesse donc de
la mère et de son enfant depuis la
conception jusqu'à la fin du premier
mois de vie de l'enfant
depuis que je suis en hospitalisation à
domicile on me demande d'intervenir
majoritairement quand tout devrait être
joyeux et que ça ne l'est pas pour x
raisons et donc dans ce cas là on
travaille en équipe avec les équipes
hospitalières où les équipes
de pmi qui nous confient les patients
peuvent balancer ça qu'on cherche pour
expliquer pourquoi vous avez tenté
d'approcher prématurément dans façon
interne et ça changera pas grand chose
et puis cattin ce n'est pas une
augmentation le boulot c'est pour vivre
même si j'aime beaucoup mon travail
c'est pas l'essentiel de ma vie la fois
nourri mon travail et mon travail nourri
ma foi ça c'est évident parce que si je
restais au plan strictement humain je
pense qu'il ya des fois je n'arriverai
pas à trouver d'ouverture avec mes
patientes
j'admire mes collègues qui n'ont pas
leur foi parce que je ne sais pas où est
ce qu'elle trouve l'énergie dans
certaines situations de donner de
l'espérance et d'ouvrir des portes des
patients vous n'êtes pas en train de
vous dire qu'il ya peut-être encore
trois semaines après il ya évidemment
des situations de détresse auquel je
suis pas insensible et là je peux les
remettre dans la prière et ma foi me
donne une espérance personnel sûr que je
sais que le travail que j'ai fait ne
m'appartient pas que j'ai peut-être se
met peut-être pas semer mais que je peux
remettre ce travail au seigneur et et il
est surtout la vie de ses patientes au
seigneur il est présenté pour que lui
agissent puisque lui peu ce que moi je
ne peux pas faire mon nom du coup tiré
des compléments beaucoup de familles ont
deux trois enfants ce qui veut dire que
ils vivent une grossesse et une
naissance deux à trois fois dans leur
vie
j'ai la chance d'être témoin de vul de
ces histoires-là plusieurs fois par jour
au quotidien on assiste à un mirage
c'est quand même époustouflant de voir
arriver à la vie un minimum comme 18 des
étudiantes que j'avais eue en stage
c'est un être humain en devenir et c'est
parfaitement miraculeux et je le vois
tous les jours et je vois bien que là ya
plein de choses qui nous dépassent
pourquoi madame machin va accoucher tel
joueur est pas le lendemain
pourquoi telle naissance va très bien se
passer et celle là qui est dans le même
contexte va plutôt mal se passer
pourquoi tel maman va avoir ses
difficultés plus que sa voisine
il ya toujours des problématiques
médicales et humaine qui me dépasse et
c'est là que je me rends compte que que
dieu saint vite c'est un vide dans ma
vie et dans la vie de mes patients pour
veiller sur eux et pour faire jaillir la
vie là où on ne l'attend pas toujours
pas toujours de la manière dont on
l'attendrait en tout cas je m'engage pas
sur l'espérance de mes patientes
je peux leur communiqué mon
émerveillement face à leurs enfants et
face à leur choix mais c'est évident
qu'une patiente qui fait le choix de
mener une grossesse à terme alors
qu'elle ne l'a pas désiré donc qui
refusent une interruption volontaire de
grossesse
c'est un choix personnel très important
et parfois au moment de la naissance
c'est un enfant qui est difficile à
accueillir moi je sais que j'ai une
espérance parce que il a reçu des
qualités il est aimé de dieu et de ses
parents même si parfois cet amour se
manifestent difficilement ou qu'il a du
mal à s'exprimer
moi j'ai une espérance personnel
maintenant professionnellement je me
dois de dépister les situations à risque
à risque de maltraitance à risque de
complications psychologique voire
psychiatrique pour les parents
mon travail c'est dans ces situations là
de voir quelles peuvent être les petits
signes avant coureurs et de suggérer un
accompagnement pour que justement quand
l'espérance n'est pas là on puisse
essayer d'en trouver une
et on puisse aider cet amour difficile
on puisse l'aider à naître et vous
donnez de conduiront à la demande par
contre ils réclament quittait ce qui
fait les deux sens moi je préfère qu'il
est moins complet - qui t'a fait de
l'accouchement n'est pas toujours fini
dans le coeur des parents et mon travail
c'est de finir la fin de cet
accouchement je sache rien jusqu'au bout
même journée aux abois
il va rien de valeur